shakespeare goethe schiller brecht circa
200 mal ist im vergangenen jahrzehnt der
faust auf deutschsprachigen bühnen zu
sehen gewesen
180 mal die räuber 170 mal die
dreigroschenoper ökonomischen würde man
so etwas eine menge wirtschaft
das theater der gegenwart leidet an
einem mangel an simon
ich habe gerade die fasnet anmeldung
bekommen
die theater müssen wieder zu machen und
jetzt stehe ich gerade die theatersäle
jetzt zu ende und denken wir was machen
wir jetzt durch würde sagen wir machen
es gerade deswegen umso mehr
also ich meine klar der lok dann kommt
die theater gehen wieder zu was bedeutet
es eigentlich ich glaube dass wir jetzt
gerade wieder stärker über die frage
nachdenken sollen was ist das derart was
für einen wert hat das eigentlich
unserer gesellschaft ja durch die lok
tor wird ja gesagt das theater ist
systemrelevant ok aber was ist das denn
dann
wir subventionieren das theater her mit
unglaublich viel geld jedes jahr in
deutschland eigentlich finde ich wir
versuchen ja mit unseren film eine
antwort zu geben auf die frage was der
gesellschaftliche wert der rückhalt
solcher theaterstücke aus dem 17 18 19
jahrhundert was bedeuten die heute und
das ist heute glaube ich wichtiger denn
je
in einer zeit wo wir auf absehbare zeit
eben nicht mehr ins theater gehen können
und wir bringen
sozusagen den menschen des theaters nach
hause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit unserem format wollen wir reisen
unternehmen reisen an unterschiedliche
orte in vergangenen epochen zu
verschiedenen dramatikerinnen und
dramatiker die alle theaterstücke
geschrieben haben die zu unrecht
vergessen worden sind und die themen und
fragen behandelt die auch unsere zeit
umtreiben die uns betreffen
das sind fragen nach dem geschlecht nach
der liebe nach gewalt nach emanzipation
und religionskonflikt
deshalb wird es in unseren folgen auch
nie nur um die theaterstücke an sich
gehen sondern immer auch um die themen
die unsere zeit bestimmen und umtreiben
in diesem theater reisen die wir
unternehmen wollen wird es immer
reiseführerin vielheit geben die an
unterschiedlichen orten mit
verschiedenen gästen in die stücke und
die welt der stücke einführen werden und
eine dieser reise führen ist charlotte
wunderbar dass du da bist charlotte das
theater was bedeutet das eigentlich für
dich ich meine wie auch gehst du so ins
theater ich würde sagen wenn es hoch
kommt so ein mal im monat und wenn dann
überlege ich mir schon sehr genau was
ich mir angucke für mich ist die
hemmschwelle da einfach ein bisschen
höher als zum beispiel ins kino zu gehen
oder abends zu hause eine serie zu
gucken ja die fragen ja viele aber warum
ist das so was glaubst du ich glaube das
ist manchmal einfach schwieriger so
einen zugang zu finden zu diesen alten
texten und so ging es mir auch bei
diesem stück der druck von salomon am
ski das wurde in warschau uraufgeführt
in den 20er jahren und das ist ein total
wichtiges theaterstück in der jüdischen
theater geschichte und auch als ich das
erste mal gelesen habe dachte ich erst
mal so hell worum geht's hier ich
verstehe das überhaupt nicht und dann
habe ich einen zugang gefunden und zwar
auch über die autorin debra feldmann
lieh mir erklärt hat was das stück für
sie bedeutet toll und die wirst du
mitnehmen auf deine reise deborah
feldmann und wenn doch dann nehme ich
auch noch mit einer schauspielerin anna
platten und einen schauspieler jeff will
busch den kennt man aus der serie und
orthodox von netflix und auch aus bad
banks und genau die beiden werden szenen
aus dem stück spielen super der freuen
uns drauf vielen dank charlotte
wer jetzt schon mal eines der markanten
beispiele eines vergessenen
theaterstücks kennen gelernt dass uns
direkt in fragen und konflikte der
gegenwart bringt da machen wir das ganze
eigentlich hier vor der volksbühne ein
wenn man so will monumental ischen ort
der theatergeschichte ein ort der wie
kein zweiter für die dekonstruktion die
auf sprengung von stoffen steht aber
eben auch für den literarischen wagemut
und den entdeckergeist hier in diesem
theater soll es in absehbarer zeit eine
lange nacht der vergessenen stücke geben
in der auf vielfältige weise die
vergessenen theaterstücke präsentiert
diskutiert so werden sollen an gespielt
gelesen und beschimpft und gefeiert mit
partys konzerten und allem drum und dran
es soll eigentlich im wesentlichen darum
gehen hier das kulminieren zulassen dass
uns umfeld nämlich den kanon neu zu
bestimmen ihn aufzureißen sich nach
neuen figuren charakteren und handlungen
umzuschauen und dem theater eben der
gegenwart zu beweisen dass mehr möglich
ist als immer nur das gleiche
hier kommen wir jetzt zu einem weiteren
reiseführer auf der reise in die
vergessenen theater landschaften kevin
freue mich sehr dass du dabei müssten
auch bei dir die erste frage was
bedeutet das theater eigentlich für dich
persönlich
das theater ist für mich ein
sehnsuchtsort auf der suche nach
identifikation ein schaufenster zum
zeitgeist aus dem ich meine
implikationen für mein eigenes leben
ableiten möchte und stücke wie mutter
courage oder kabale und liebe haben mich
zwar an das theater herangeführt aber
ich kann mich heutzutage kaum mehr mit
den hauptprotagonisten identifizieren
und deshalb denke ich dass es notwendig
ist dass es neue starke charaktere im
theater braucht neue moderne
hauptprotagonisten interessanterweise
findest du aber einen solchen modernen
haupt eine hauptcharakter nicht in einem
teilstück der gegenwart der
gegenwartsdramatik sondern in einem
vergangenen vergessenen stück welches
ist dass das stück ist gabriel von
george sand aus dem jahr 1809
30 und das ist eine verwechslung ein
verwechslung drama welches sich ja mit
sehr vielen fragen beschäftigt die uns
die heute von extremer relevanz und die
frage nach emanzipation die frage nach
geschlechter identität das pendeln
zwischen den geschlechtern es geht um
eine junge frau die als junger mann
aufgezogen wird und auf der suche nach
ihrer identität ist das klingt
spektakulär zeitgemäß und durchaus auch
mit konflikten mit wem wirst du denn
dieses stück besprechen wir werden da
die gäste seien über das stück werde ich
mit der journalistin anna b herr
sprechen die es in paris in einem
antiquariat entdeckt hat mit laura labs
einer regisseurin und drag queen nina
queer super das klingt faszinierend
unspektakulär vielen dank kevin ja vom
talmud schüler bis zur drag queen das
ungefähr das repertoire das spektrum
dass wir abschalten wollen mit unserer
theater serie spielplan änderung in den
nächsten wochen von monaten
[Applaus]
[Musik]